good morning John it doesn't matter what
date is because he's not gonna see this
for a while because you're on a boat in
the middle of the ocean in Europe or
something and I'm totally confused I
never really know what you're doing
anymore just because there's no ending
out on the Buddhism you can't vlog okay
yes does anyway this video comes in five
parts but one my new glasses if you look
really close and in the right light
they're green mm-hmm very happy with
them so thank you very much to the
nerdfighters and all of YouTube for let
me choose these wonderful new glasses
they were very cheap the way I did it
second I'm proud to announce the winner
of the going postal nerdfighting
blurbing book club it was Emily went
postal would go again which I completely
agree with so Emily I hope you will
enjoy your prize which is number three
the non-existent nerdfighting prize of
the day but non-existent Federer press
of the day is something that I've been
doing in my head for a while sometimes I
put in the comments and sometimes I just
think about it here's how this began
things up Jen and I are actually very
good at actually giving rewards to the
people who deserve rewards like the
people who plan the blubbering book club
in the past haven't actually received
anything in the way of rewards so bad
really got at it embarrassingly bad at
it even so the not exist at nerdfighting
precedent the day is given to a
nerdfighter as a badge of honor you
deserve something we just happen to be
too lame to actually get it to you so
the non-existent Impreza that it has a
few advantages over actual prizes first
you can show it off to every woman
anyone every one of the world not just
people who happen to be nearby you you
get it immediately as soon as you
deserve it it's there you've got it all
so there's no shipping it off so it
doesn't produce any carbon dioxide on
transport and you're never sure who's
gonna get it you're never sure it could
be civil with an exceptionally good
comment it could be the winner of the
nerdfighting boarding book club it could
be the person who designs the best
graphic for the non-existent
nerdfighting present the day in fact if
I get a really good awards graphic for
the non-existent nerdfighting present
the day in my inbox at sparks fly epic
gmail.com I will definitely give that
person the non-existent nerf reading
prize of the day or I've heard from four
of the five people who bought my album
at the rock Reggie's terminus show if
you're the fifth person please email me
this is something that I will actually
send and I have no idea what number I'm
on this is why I don't do parts videos a
secret project now intelligent and
diligent nerdfighters will probably know
what this is about but whether or not
you do I'm absolutely
positive that you want to be involved
it's very exciting you have an
opportunity to do something pretty
amazing but we're gonna need a lot of
nerdfighter help to do it if you go to
nerdfighters con right now or you click
the link in the sidebar you'll find a
sign up the same list is the secret
project for awesome lists so if you did
that an email address hasn't changed
since then you don't have to worry about
it but everybody else if you want to be
involved in the project you do have to
do that because that's the only way
we're gonna be talking about this stuff
okay
and lastly did I say this with five
parts this is more than five parts I
don't know what's going on we are
closing submissions for the nerd
fighting t-shirt design contest and I'm
about to show you in a rapid motion all
of the exciting teachers from
nerdfighters you can vote on them at
nerdfighters comm lots of good things
from people like Stark I tones and lots
of things from people and I didn't even
know I really loved some of these there
are lots and I couldn't even fit in the
video so I'm very excited to find out
which of these shirts we will be
printing we may take the top three we
may take the top four I'm not sure but
some of these shirts will be available
on the great American tour - nerd
fighting nerds readers you can go -
nerdfighters come right now and vote on
which is your favorite shirt or if
you're at nerdfighters calm right now
you can look right above this video and
there will be images of all the shirts
and a little script that will let you
vote on your favorite
John I'm pretty sure I'm gonna get my
next video up before you get your
Catcher in the Rye video up and if I'm
wrong about that then I'll see you then
but if I'm right then I'll see me first
oh my god I forgot a thing last thing
for real this time
John started a new scavenger hunt and
this time it's European the first school
is in Sweden it's been found and been
deciphered so far we have the letter B
and we don't know whether letter B means
and I don't know what the letter B means
either forward to finding out Kevin
Durrant
[Music]